من ذوي المدافع هذه الى نيران التحذير
والوعيد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي حذر الغرب من مساعد تسليح اوكرانيا
باسلحه ثقيله وانظمه هجوميه
متواعدا بان خساره قوه النوويه مثل روسيا
في حرب تقليديه ستؤدي الى اندلاع حرب
النوويه تحذير عززه الكرملين واكد
بالاضافه ان تحذيرات من الحرب النوويه
تتوافق تماما مع العقيده النوويه الروسيه
يتزمن ذلك مع تحولات جذريه
حيث تدرس اداره الرئيس الامريكي
رساله لقياف لمساعدتها في ضرب شبه جزيره
القرم التي ضمتها روسيا عام 2014 وفقا
يورك تايمز الصحيفه اضافت انه بعد اشهر من
المناقشات مع المسؤولين الاوكرانيين بدات
اداره بيض اخيرا لاعتراف بانك قد تحتاج
الى القوه لضرب هذا الملاذ الروسيه حتى لو
كانت هذه الخطوه ستزيد من خطر التصعيد
القرم الواقعه بين البحر الاسود وبحر اذوب
موطن لعشرات الالاف من الجنود الروس روسيا
تعتمد الى حد كبير على قواعدها العسكريه
في شبه جزيره القرم في شن هجمات مكانتها
من الاستيلاء على الاراضي جنوبيه اوكرانيا
العام الماضي
الولايات المتحده اصرت ولسنوات على ان
القرم لا تزال جزءا من اوكرانيا
اعطونا اسلحتكم سنستعيد ارضنا
جزيره القرم تعود لواجهه الاحداث من جديد
مسار اخر تدخله الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
مع سعي كل طرف للسيطره على كامل اراضي شبه
جزيره القرم